(soft gentle music)
- Okay, here we go.
Don't eat that fast.
You're gonna yack it
all up like a baby bird.
Spit it out.
Aw Christ, look at that, Jesus.
- Put the gun down, please?
- Put the gun down bitch!
- Please, please?
I don't want to know what
they're gonna say about me.
- Nana, no, no, no, no, please,
please please please,
no, no, no, Nana, no.
(gun clicks)
- What the hell?
- Oh, put that down, Nana.
(gun shot)
(thump)
- Oh!
- Oh my God, Nana, you shot Ricardo!
Oh my God, oh my God (crying)
- You shot me!
- Oh, wow, I'm sorry, no,
wow, I didn't mean to do that.
(buzzer vibrating)
- Oh (whistles) it's blinking.
- I can take your buzzer.
- You are being a rude little toad.
- He's-
- You sit down, sit down!
Oh my God.
- Ma'am?
Ma'am, calm--
- What the hell is going on here?
- Ma'am, calm down.
She's all right-
- Just get away from her.
Get away from her.
- Ma'am!
- Who the hell are you anyway?
- I'm the ER nurse.
Infinity said she fainted.
We're just gonna do
some routine blood work
while we asked you some
questions about your-
- Oh no, you are not taking
any blood from this girl.
Payton Hobart knew.
He knew every God damn thing,
that rich little son of a bitch.
- You can't smoke in here.
- Oh, of course I can smoke in here.
- You think I should kill him?
- What?
Yes, yes I do.
You come waltzing in here
with that ridiculous sweater,
that fancy hair.
You have no right to treat us like that.
Are you wearing a wire?
- Hm?
- Am I being recorded?
- No.
- Well then I have something to say.
- Okay?
- This is what being a
celebrity is all about.
You never have to pay for anything.
Look at that.
Go ahead.
Do it.
C'mon, let's have a Buddhist barbecue.
That's what gays do.
Munch, butts, and celebrate Halloween.
And then, you know, I've been thinking,
and I might have some
psychological problems,
you know, and I think I
probably need to get some help.
- Nana.
It's really, really great
to hear you say them.
- Yes, and that's why I've
just booked a spa vacation.
- Huh?
- 10 whole days of like
facials and massage.
I think it's gonna do me a-
- You booked a spa vacation?
- I need help!
Hello, gentlemen.
- Mrs. Jackson, do you mind if we come in?
(orchestra music)
Your boyfriend, ha, he is
taking advantage of you.
You have the IQ of a kindergartner.
(door slams)
- Jesus H. Christ, can't you knock?
You can be vice president.
Aim high.
You can get it all.
If it worked for him
she'd be sitting here,
right now at this table
with us, her family,
Listening to Shirley Bassey
and watching me drink.
Here are her medical records,
the last five years, go ahead.
Read 'em, son of a bitch.
Go ahead, read 'em.
Jesus H. Christ, it's like Rome.
I mean, all you can eat,
and then a quick trip to the vomitorium.
Dining out used to be
something you earned,
well, like you have.
So much for, hey!
What the hell is wrong with you?
You don't reach over someone's plate.
You ask it to be passed.
- [Infinity] Can I have it be passed?
- Jesus Christ, he's
going to get more food.
- Yeah.
- What are you saying, that
I went down into the basement
and peeled paint chips off the wall,
and fed them to your mother?
- Yeah, that's exactly what I think.
- Oh, I got it, 30 years ago,
when I was working on a used
car lot, it was the 80's.
crack was just beginning.
I caught him masturbating in
front of my granddaughter.
Oh, I did a little bit
of reporting myself.
I called the school about him.
Wait a minute, we could
make some money on this?
- Absolutely, oh, absolutely.
- Well, hot damn.
Oh honey, you can't just eat macaroons.
You're gonna end up with diabetes.
But that's an animated film, Infinity.
Rats don't actually work there.
She's all alone, living
in a motel for God's sake.
She also has a raisin allergy.
Did somebody, did you, did
somebody here give her a raisin?
- No, ma'am.
- [Dusty] Her doctors
and I will handle this.